can an IV bag Cara Hangul we've created
a facility to test the world's greatest
hangover cures and we're testing them
all I'm dr. Keller wertham doctor of
internal medicine I'm Frank Krantz I'm
not a doctor that I've been hung over a
lot welcome to the GQ hangover lab so
what's your name John so you have fun
last night yeah yeah
well let's check it out right what
alcohols Oh vodka vodka and so you've
got a vodka energy no I'm getting ready
to go mix a bunch of caffeine and energy
with your alcohol it's going to
artificially allow you to kind of stay
alert and drink more yeah that was just
down the hatch with the bottle yeah I
wasn't measuring shot so I was just
about yeah I was bottling it yeah I had
how do you feel
guy soccer match in here and a
gymnastics routine in here now
you know we've run some tests on you we
tested your vital signs you know we did
the breathalyzer you're at 0.03 still we
gave you five minutes to see how far you
could get assembling some Swedish
furniture
I have no comments right now we're gonna
attempt to cure you and then we're gonna
put you through all the same tests and
we're gonna hope for better results
especially with the shelf because I
actually need one he just kind of looked
bad right he was kind of slurring his
words he just seemed a little grumpy
there was kind of this nihilist sort of
theme throughout that there's no point
to anything alcohol is a depressant so
people feel depressed from it yeah you
wake up that next morning it's like oh
man like not only do I feel shitty but
like this [ __ ] and he's got the headache
he's got the upset stomach issues it's
classic yeah he kind of has the ultimate
cure coming his way right John has what
I would probably call the gold standard
in hangover cure a liter of saline with
a lot of different antioxidants vitamins
electrolytes and these are all things
that he's suffering from right now a
loss of antioxidants because they all
been chewed up by the alcohol metabolism
a loss of electrolytes because he's your
innate AddThis of fluid as well yeah
he'd mention he was pretty cottonmouth
have a seat John we have a real treat is
that my pee that it's not your pee that
is a special formulated IV bag and we've
got a team here from the Cure LA who's
gonna tell us what's in it so this
treatment has sterile water infused with
multiple different vitamins and
electrolytes it has magnesium vitamin C
vitamin b-complex which has a body means
to be one through five as well as
vitamin b12 it's a quick process runs
over about 10 to 15 minutes and usually
people feel the effects right after the
treatment is finished I love it start
you're probably able to taste those B
vitamins yeah I'll call out the taste
but yes it's definitely some weird stuff
not after that we're gonna redo all the
testing and see if you've improved
especially on the Swedish furniture
construction I really need the storage
space how you doing John you look better
yeah it's 9-day man I can't wait to get
this out of me and just go about my day
and just get back to work and do
whatever I do I feel great I've never
been tired my nausea is gone I mean fine
great and and do you feel you're more
focused like if we put you to build
Swedish furniture you're gonna match it
looking forward to building the
furniture easy Berta 135 over 18 your
blood pressure came up a little bit
calling some more where it lives and I
think you're just be hydrating it looks
like you're a little bit more relaxed
you folks a little bit lower
102 let's see how you do and be
cognitive ready go
basically what we're testing here is
more or less your cognitive ability your
problem-solving fine motor skills and
your focus you got ten seconds left
three two okay
thank you I'll bring this home with me
let's go to a safe place where we can
all talk and you talk about what
happened to the perfect my B bag works
assembling furniture sucks
when you came in first there was there
was no sense of really like either
wanting to do it or organization you
were you're agitated with it you weren't
really focused I mean would you
recommend this based on how you feel
definitely yeah my hammer is definitely
gone gone I've never been able to say
that in that says it all it looks like
you're gonna have some construction work
to do this afternoon those things make
no sense but I think the hangover cure
made sense yeah totally I think he
actually used the words my hangover is
gone I mean I think this is an easy
grade yeah yeah oh yeah this this is
this is my A+ I'm giving out my a plus
for the hangover cure I mean eat the IV
bag you sort of have to yeah I'm gonna
just stash a few of those bags all right
I'd be a weird thing to find if I had
you over in my place and you open the
wrong cupboard you're like what are the
bags for I'm dr. Keller world oh I'm
Fran Kranz thanks for visiting the
hangover lab
for more hangover cures and our grades
on them subscribe to the channel and
like us oh yeah you deserve to be like
yeah we do